she like all your brothers is here your
sister's here by my older everybody back
in the crib I'm like damn I'm over here
living in this crib with this wolf right
now
bro your Life's a move yeah I know about
that yeah it was it was too loud bro
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dope as
YOLO whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast I am with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys guys uh you can
quit bugging all right quit dming me
it's finally here this is the Disney
ride episode thank you for being here
man thank you for having me and before
we started it's been we just discovered
your
it's been almost at seven years and I've
seen you then yeah yeah it's probably
been that long it's been a long time bro
yeah a very long time and I po because I
was like getting ready for the episode
I'm like man I haven't seen some of
these clips I found remember when I
brought you to uh
that event and we basically blacked out
on the chicken wings and lemonades yeah
I meet my homie tonight with the dreads
he's coming he just moved back I'm
meeting him after this a word yeah cause
we're working on a company with his
lemonades together oh yeah you got to
tell them I said what's up it's
all right but yeah I was just going
through my pictures just seeing it's
it's a trip thinking back like it's been
that long but it doesn't feel like it
yeah I agree truly and before we get on
it before I forget every single person
out there they you're the one that put
me on Hennessy and apple juice
everyone asked me thousands of comments
why are you chasing that was why you
know my friend showed me a long time ago
I swear to God without a four-year kick
on that hey yeah I was on it for a long
time I had to stop I feel like the
Hennessy kind of went like this yeah
no I did an event it was just something
that I enjoyed but I also got off the
Hennessy as well because it did do it
started getting weird it started getting
almost like a like a wake-up film like
fantasy yeah like what's that Hennessy
yeah exactly and I just stopped I just
stopped all together but yeah the four
year span guys it's because this man
right here just little sip of apple
juice after you're done yeah that's it
and then I saw you had the song Come Out
Iris uh eye contact for the respect you
said that to me
when we're in exhibit Studio when you
were doing the fully Money Mayweather
song yeah I was working on growing
process show this I mean you're like
tell me what you think and you guys were
all hitting the shots and like what are
you saying and then everybody's staring
at each other's eyes all right it's a
thing all right it's a thing that was a
good night man it was a good night uh
other than that we get mods on that
giant dab and he like Ben we passed out
yeah yeah I think about that all the
time he was he was like his head was
full-blown red yeah I remember that yeah
that was a that was one of my first uh
LA Chill nights honestly dude I never
did nothing before and then no the last
time I saw was you and Dan Rick's music
video with all the packs and the flight
attendant oh yeah yeah okay that's the
last time we've seen each other damn
yeah it's been a long time when was that
like 16 probably
yes it was 16. it's 2016. yeah another
year I moved here yeah it's crazy wow
time's flying so you have three babies
now I do wow man one's 12 you're about
to have a teenage daughter oh my God
it's crazy I hope you're strong yeah
yeah your daughter's cool though I like
her his daughter's she's the the low-key
wild teenager like she's respectful
she's not doing crazy things yeah you
know I mean that's what's important you
teach them and raise them but yeah he's
just getting into it you're about to
step into it yeah I'm still babyless so
you know I'll be chilling for a minute
but on that note since we're here let's
spark these joints yeah yeah let's get
right so whenever you want if that runs
out I got a joint for you thank you sir
appreciate you what do we got here uh
this is lemon poppers you want full
American Psycho on these things
yesterday you're labeling them oh yeah
what do they do yeah I had this all
labeled up
um so your album drops today
yes yes well I mean this doesn't come
out right now but the album is dropping
today it drops today all right how long
are you working on this one for
um
like I started maybe
the end of last year uh like October
maybe oh no [__] how many uh can you say
how many songs are on it yeah there's um
uh
12 songs and two skits
I believe so yeah like two little skits
and 12 songs yeah it's a quick cool
little project easy Listen to Nice man
yeah no I was trying like when we were
like I said when they talked said that
you're coming I was trying to explain
like nah
live with Daddy Max live at daddy Max
what was the inspiration behind the
cover art I'm a graphic designer so I
like I'm obsessed with cover art it's my
thing well um I wanted something that
was kind of cohesive with the music so
the music is um
feels like um
like old school music kind of revamped a
little bit
um
and it's groovy it's like funky it's
groovy it's um it really doesn't sound
like anything that's out right now so I
wanted the artwork to represent like
you know like grooviness like um 70s
kind of
um feel to it a little bit but
Funkadelic kind of yeah kind of
Funkadelic you know what I mean
um I'm not all the way
I'm not all the way sure exactly what I
wanted it to be so shout out to Casey
who did all my artwork for
um
this project he did all the artwork for
the singles and he did the album but I
put the music in his hands so he could
hear it and he made it that way yeah so
he can
I wanted to see if he felt what I felt
you know what I mean that's how you're
supposed to do it and he did and um he
was able to you know really bring that
to life so that's my favorite style that
70s vintage like those old Hendrix
posters like Vibe it's just my [__]
no I feel you
um so that's dropping I know I said it
again but that's that's pretty awesome
man this is dropping a couple hours you
said yeah
are you doing anything else for the rest
after this for the album drop so I'll be
chilling um no this is all I'm doing
before the show tonight so tour starts
tonight
um here in La at catch one so it gets
created a later tour with Jaron Benton
and dimrick and myself we kicking off
tonight damn so I'm pretty much this
album is we're doing it different like
it's not like the typical like put the
project out and let the fans live with
the project
it's more like put the project out and I
want the fans to come out and experience
something new with me so if you've seen
my shows before you haven't really seen
what we're about to go out here and do
it's we're doing a lot of new music and
we're inviting people into this this new
element that we're tapping into we're
not trying to like Linger on the older
stuff you know there's some some
Classics that we will tap into of course
but
we want to lean on the new music and
bring people in and and introduce them
to this new Vibe because we just feel
like it's refreshing everything kind of
feels the same so we're just trying to
um you know get out that box I was
saying let's start a new chapter yeah
I'm assuming some live music some line
of instruments on this absolutely yeah
absolutely gonna be sick
it's so much more difficult to do that
when producing an album get in there
with like actual musicians and use
instruments versus just going in there
with Beats but it really makes all the
difference well you know shout out to
Mike and keys Mike and keys did the full
album for me
um a lot of them know
um know them for doing nipsey's last
album and
um they really came in and
gave me a sound that like
it's like an untapped into sound right
now you know I'm excited for you guys to
hear the whole thing they did the whole
thing so it's and then Mars came in who
um is like the third member in their
producer group their producer group is
called three ninjas
it initially started out with Mike and
Keith producing the album and Mars came
in and really put the sauce on the top
and like you know we were able to like
cultivate this music together so it's a
lot different than I've done it in the
past where
I'm just experienced life and um you
know I'm talking about what inspired me
or how I want to inspire people
and putting that on the music and
putting it out you know how'd you work
with them before
no
so I've known him for a long time but we
haven't been able to was it different
than with producers that you worked with
in the past like in terms of like all
right here's the vocals let's see what
you do with it and then what they came
back with oh yeah um and it wasn't even
um
because a lot of the stuff that they
gave me worked like you know I was kind
of in my bag when I was coming up with
some of these Melodies and some of the
concepts and things like that but them
being there and to kind of like
confirmed that
that was the proper direction to go I
think gave me a lot of motivation you
know what I'm saying so instead of just
you know me being like hey this is this
is what I'm going through in life so in
my projects you know I'll say my age a
lot I actually don't say my age in this
at all that lets you know something but
something different all my projects I
normally say my age because I'm trying
to state where I'm at in my in my
growing process right like that way
depending on where you're at you can
kind of compare yeah so
um
kind of out of that element after doing
10 years independent
and kind of like
you know doing things the way that I
wanted to do things and pushing my pen
the way that I wanted to push my pen and
put the messages out that I wanted to
put out without anybody telling me that
I couldn't
um I've always been happy with that you
know now it's really about just
seeing how far we can take this musician
how big it can sound how different it
can sound how original we can be
you got that fan base that's what I was
just gonna say strong strong you're
making music to serve your fan base
basically like at the end of the day
that's what we found Works do what your
fans want yeah and this one's a little
different though I feel like you're like
let me just try something I'm almost not
comfortable with because once you got
the validation of them like yeah that's
Direction you should be taking this like
you say I almost got inspired like it's
a it's like a public speaking for the
first time you're not sure if you're
good at you come off stage like yo you
think yeah it gives you a little boost
of like all right I'm in the right
direction the right path that's not a
thing yeah I'm excited for this one it's
gonna be different it's gonna be sick
yeah it's definitely different
um anybody uh you said
you had Gerard and then who else Denmark
are on this you said oh just show oh the
tour Jaren Benton thank you um on the
album where's the hat right where's like
a lot of Bill is he bought a ball dude
right jiren right yeah yeah I think I
know you're talking about yeah you got
the body
on the album I just have problem and TD
Banks okay so I did an open verse
challenge for one of my fans to be on
the album so I put the the record out
there and they were able to
do their verses and submit their verses
and you know we picked the winner and
that winner
um on your album is on my album oh so
yeah and he came with it his name TD
Banks he did his thing where's he from
he's from Chicago
originally I think he's from Detroit but
he's he's stationed in Chicago very
talented artist
um and he did his thing what made you
decide to Willy won it's a really cool
idea I've never heard of that number one
a chance experience like that's a life I
love that he could be nine years ago hey
put that song
you're you're solidifying them you know
what I mean yeah that's dope what would
just randomly thought there's got to be
somewhere out there dope he just did it
yeah you know I think
um
sometimes when I when I think about
artists who I want to work with I can't
always necessarily see who fits what I'm
on
you know I know that I can adjust to
what other artists do sometimes but you
know
certain artists can adjust to what I do
sometimes and then you have like some of
the greats that can come in that came in
over my career really did their thing
like big crit and Tech N9ne and currency
and Mazi and some of these dudes that
were able to tap into what I had going
on
but with this I didn't want to force
anything like I didn't want to try to
just find bigger names to to you know
get their fan base and I know that's the
game you kind of got to play
but it's like I'm revamping myself it's
like I'm back live at daddy Max where
I'm not really tripping off that I'm
like
I just want to put out Dope music with
dope people and like if I could put an
opportunity out there for an artist to
like be able to shed some light you know
I feel like it's going to be a little
more passionate than somebody who
already has the light already shining on
them so
um I took the chance because I felt like
you know over my career I've been able
to
you know um attract good people you know
whether it's artists or it's the fans or
it's whoever like some of the some of
the verses we got back were fired some
of the verses we got back were trash you
know but a lot of the verses had good
subject matters you know like a lot of
you could tell were like thoughtful
people whether it was good or bad you
know so I'm glad that I was able to
attract it's not like [__] was
sending me verses back about shooting up
the club or like that's a good point
though taking a bunch of drugs or some
[__] right like that's not what I
attract so
it was a cool experience what a cool way
to sample the fan base oh man and right
like you get nothing but positivity and
deep ass messages like hey I know it
it's just the same thing like if I go
out to a meet and greet and I like I
went to Texas to meet me right
I didn't expect if I was it's Texas I
was signing extended clips and guns but
that's the culture but they everybody
that had them was like so happy and high
five like and I'm like you hold it
I want my fingerprints on your [__] but
I did sign a couple Clips but that's
just the way of life but nobody was
weird nobody came through with a weird
game they were gang banger ass fools
and that's what I try to bring out of
people yeah that's what I try to give
off I'm happy that that's what's
reciprocated nice for and then same
thing with your musically I got some
sick [__] nobody's telling me about
popping Percocets not a lot of rappers
can say that no hell no majority of the
submissions I got in this contest were
thoughtful
you know I appreciated that part of it
you know what I'm saying so
it was a cool experience that's cool and
the fact he put him on the album oh man
that was juicy always count down days
the hours right now I'd be sick to see
like next time you do it if you do it
again like film it film yourself you
just cut you're sitting there listening
to all the different beats you like
little samples of them I got I got some
footage of of some of it for sure like
because it wasn't just me it was a
process like I had all my homies in
there we listened to this together you
know what I'm saying but I think the
main the the
um best part about it all is
um
we were able to choose somebody and it's
a verse that I love mm-hmm
so you know the artist that we chose it
wasn't like I just had to choose
somebody right like it was a verse the
best of the worst it's like it's what I
would want my fans to hear
you know so cool experience of both ends
yeah work very cool shout out to TD
Banks
Juiced you know he's juice right now
when you were younger like yo Cartoon
Network like my post I don't know
whatever you did as a kid like you know
they put me on an episode
it's just like you know like I said
ingrained but before I forget I wanted
to say this earlier I was thinking about
it on the drive here
first time I ever went to uh your spot
out in Vegas I don't remember how old
you must have you're what a year you're
32. yeah you're gonna younger than me so
I was like 24 25 but I remember going
into your gated spot
I never met a young fool on his [__]
that I had just because I'm from the
poor ass part of California right we get
an apartment like damn you got your own
apartment [__] whenever I walked in and
I think it was you and freezing I was
like
it's your house I love it I'm so happy
for this and then I was just like yo
this is the way of life for you
I gotta I gotta do something this is
great it wasn't more like well I bet you
I could do it this month it's super nice
he's a pie and I could do it too yeah I
just moved to a gay community first time
ever last month and I thought of your
ass the first time I pulled in like
I remember pulling in I remember what
car you had but I remember there's a car
outside went
crushing it and I just remember we
played video games and smoke like this
is the level of
piece that I need to accomplish where
and you had hella toys for your well now
12 year old daughter but that's scary
just think about it again but yeah yeah
is that the first time you had seen
somebody living uh anybody that didn't
live with their parents or in an
apartment ever in my life
as before I ever anyway
yeah so I remember that [__] I
remembered things like that man just
because I remember I moved to like
yeah
it's good [__] man it's just motivation
I just remember thinking back like one
day so one day here we are and here we
are and you did it congratulations no
thank you man I just that's incredible
stoked stoked stuff to be here right now
I'm [__] high as hell too
incredible all right let's continue
let's continue before I start
go ahead Marty
so
I mean just kind of going off that
if you were to like for somebody that
doesn't know break down all the projects
that you've been putting out over the
years independently like going back to
even that time frame like what does that
look like
in terms of like
all the different bodies of work that
you put out
um planning ahead a lot of it is
planning ahead
um I always kind of knew what I wanted
to do next
or like
you know what I was going to tap into if
I was on tour I would like make plans to
like tap into something different or go
explore research something different and
through that I would get inspired by
things and it would just lead to like
the music and lead to the Vibes or the
community work or whatever it might be
[Music]
um but really just planning ahead the
pandemic made that weird you know what
I'm saying so it was like
they put it all at a hole and you really
had to like hit the reset button and
restart you know so
but I would still say
um back in those days it was a lot of
um planning ahead and having a vision so
I wasn't kind of like getting to a point
where I didn't know what I was going to
do and could be steered any kind of way
yeah you know or be motivated to do
something that might been yeah
um over time A lot of people are like
trout like going in different directions
that are kind of not authentic to
themselves but you can kind of look back
and be like this has really just been me
putting like my hair just got a little
bit yeah nothing you're still the same
guys
see what you're saying like people try
to put on this well I think this is what
this guy should look like yeah I mean
you can doesn't really work that way bro
yeah in this industry they convinced you
to try to get as big as possible and
then chill you know and then you know so
and then come back and you know and all
these different things and it doesn't
work like that for everybody you know
what I'm saying so I think for me I
never really had like a
chill like oh I'm not gonna put music
out this year I did well last year yeah
you know like even if I did well last
year I was still growing in real life so
it was like things that I wanted to talk
about
or
um you know things that I might have
talked about in the past in my music but
now I'm learning about it in a different
way so I want to find a different way to
talk about that you know what I'm saying
like and show the growth in that so I
use the music as a way to like Express
those things yeah
but yeah
now you told Thomas told me that you're
related to one of my favorite rappers of
all time basically
Bone Thugs-N-Harmony lazy bone right
not by Blood but yeah there's relation
there right yeah you gotta be honest I
even know that [__] yeah so recently
yeah when I buy blood my mom was the um
my mom was the road manager for Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony back in the day oh and
became like family so
yeah you let you let my you let him tell
it you know yeah I'm his nephew you know
what I'm saying but like yeah
um not by Blood but yeah that's bonus
like my family mm-hmm yeah that's
legendary to me like for my money East
1999 it's like one of the greatest
albums of all time I agree even like
were you where were you at in life when
you were like finding out about that
were you just like a deep hip-hop fan
and you're like just all in the mix what
was that I mean your mom had to be
you got to know what your Mom's doing
she's sitting there sit there I'm gonna
be managing this group it's not like you
were oblivious to it right no no
actually no we weren't so my mom's
um will go travel and go do those things
you know what I'm saying oh it's a road
management yeah my mind yeah my mom was
the road manager so she would hit the
road with bone and things like that and
um but
I was a youth reporter you know I'm
saying
um when I was a kid
I was introduced to hip-hop through my
mom like
you know she was in the industry we were
doing the youth reporting thing and then
one day she was just like
you know if I wrote the raps would you
wrap them
yeah and I was like yeah I mean if it's
gone wait how old were you uh eight
ah all right I can't wait to hear this I
did not know this yeah I was I was
eight years old like in the studio or
like on camera or some [__] like yeah no
my mom had access to Studios and stuff
like that so yeah me and my brother
would record in studios that was little
kids that's eight year olds well I by
the time we was in the studio I think I
was nine and my my little brother was
seven
and uh here we uh
we started rapping and like my mom wrote
the wraps for like hella long you know
what I'm saying and
it wasn't until I was like uh
um
13.
12 or 13. when I started to want to
write the raps
my mom was like
I don't know about this she was she like
well what it was was I was 13 and I
wanted to rap about the stuff that I was
going through 13 year old [__] you know
and my mom was like don't nobody want to
hear no no 13 year old talking about
that [__]
what like and that you know I wanted to
talk about girls and [__] she's like nah
we not talking about little girls why is
she ghost writing for you guys like what
was like positive [__] yeah like just a
bunch of positive [__] like
it's crazy it was like she was trying to
groom us to be like little positive
rappers which the irony is crazy because
I became work you know
um a positive rapper you know but they
say what you installed in them at a
young age is who they initially become
you know what I mean like the energy you
install them so but
you know at the time like that positive
[__] wasn't really
that [__] didn't make no sense to me you
know because nothing was positive like
I'm like it's you want us to rap about
some fake [__] you know what I'm saying
I'm like I got you
what the [__] is positive about anything
we going through you know what I'm
saying this don't make no sense you want
me to get up there and we're seeing
something like speaking into existence
type of [__] like trying to get you to
use your minds the she was on some we
need to motivate other kids that's the
only way it's gonna work
so the only way this kid rap [__] work
is if you can motivate the other kids
like
the dose not gonna listen to you yeah
and you can't be
the the kid that's introducing the kids
to the [__] that their parents need to
be introducing them to
so she had the mindset of just like you
gotta be a leader yeah I couldn't really
understand what the [__] she was trying
to tell me
what does that have to do with like the
fact that like none of the [__] we
talking about is like happening in our
real life all this positive [__] yeah I
almost feel like I'm just fronting over
here
even as a kid all that's hard especially
I'm like you gotta understand we was
like
I was living in a shelter
yeah she was trying to get a deal for us
like so like what era of music is this
like uh this is 2003
2004. definitely a lot of the positivity
[__] no this is the 50 Cent wave yeah
this is the G Unit weight yeah
right before social media still so it's
not viral Kidz Bop rap yeah that's what
it was
in like all playing color shirts from
Target and [__] right I remember that
era TV they try to sell those CDs and
[__] it really was that though
that's exactly what it was
look at this
and it's crazy Walmart but see this is
the thing is like I have friends in my
neighborhood that I that I hung out with
we knew our circumstances so I couldn't
play that positive [__] for them
it's hard to speak it's hard being like
that yeah
I'm out here with these [__] like
we see what's going on we know how we
gotta move how we gotta act right now
like in the eighth grade like
you came to Vegas no this in Vegas it's
like you can't just be doing I don't
think I've ever heard this version it's
always the opposite yeah give him a
suburbs trying to act hard I haven't
this is such a wild story
yeah this like the opposite exactly I I
get what it is to see my mom yeah my mom
is she trying to change that mentality
see my older brother was already
he was already a lost cause you know he
was in and out of juvie in jail and
things like that so he was making the
mistakes and my mom was just like I was
the second notice so she just like
trying to change
you know what I'm saying she did
everything she did everything right you
know what I'm saying but like I just
couldn't see it like that back then you
know what I'm saying it was tricky but
you stayed in the studio
it seems like you said there's five
years went by and you're like I know I
want to write this [__] well you know
what's crazy is it wasn't until uh
because my mom kind of gave up on the
music [__] like
you know a lot of mistakes have been
made a lot of chances have been took
that fell through and
you know she's a single parent with five
kids I mean oh damn at some point you
got to pull the trigger yeah you know
what I'm saying so she ended up pulling
the trigger and things like that and you
know I was kind of upset because I had
really now I'm two three years in a
writing my raps and I'm feeling like I'm
getting better and I'm really falling in
love with hip-hop in a different way now
you know what I'm saying differently
than how it was introduced to me it's
like it's being reintroduced to me you
know in my teens because now I'm going
through all this different music
listening to all these artists all the
[__] that I wasn't listening to when I
first came in the game
like Park like 50 like
um you know what I'm saying DJ Quick you
know Jay-Z you know some of these dudes
that was just like
um Shifting the culture
you know what I'm saying and um
and boom a lot of bone
you know I started really understanding
what bone was bringing to the culture
now I fell in love with the harmonizing
and all of that so bone really became
like top of the list who I was listening
to
um I don't feel like they get their
credit and they're like the only group
to do a song with Tupac and Biggie
it's legendary I had the molt dogs out I
had all that [__] back in the day
never thought about that yeah they are
that's very true they're out of
Cleveland but they're dialed in with the
Easy E out of La somehow like I don't I
don't know how they would did that oh
the grind is crazy yeah pre-internet
doing [__] free internet you're a
different monster you moved a whole
different mindset promoting yourself
pre-internet pre I'm on TV out of
Cleveland you gotta stress that because
nobody had come out of Cleveland
ever yeah I don't know I can't think of
[__]
all right
[Music]
guys by this point we all know I hate
inflation there's one company out there
giving you a break it's mint mobile as
the first company to sell previous
wireless service online only MIP mobile
lets you order from your house save a
ton and plan start at just 15 a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network also using
esim allows you to use your phone and
switch over to Mint mobile seamlessly to
get your new Wireless plans starting at
just 15 bucks a month get it shipped
directly to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com Yola again guys that's
mipmobile.com forward slash Yola
starting at just 15 a month these plans
couldn't get any better
[Music]
when they came out it was like one album
even their first album was huge but
creeping up on the r or whatever
but creeping up creeping up on the come
up yeah yeah
um I'll tell you a story that I I don't
think I've ever told this story
um on camera but uh
my uncle Lane
um
he the one time that he came in and he
I actually got like some songs with
with him on it when I was like a little
kid him jumping on the verses like I'm
like a little ass kid on the song like
and he got a verse on it but when I was
about
maybe 15 or 16.
he had reached out to my moms and said
that uh he wanted to start like a little
Bone Thugs-N-Harmony
called Mighty Mo Thug five right
[Laughter]
Mighty mot Thug five right and um
his vision was like you know to bring us
to Arizona and and
you know get us to record an album
and Shop that out
you know and it was me my little brother
and uh it was uh lazy son Jay bong
and it was two other artists
um Chris and three
Chris was from LA
and three was from New Orleans
and um
yeah we was we was We were supposed to
be the mighty mode the five so we went
to Arizona and
um we ended up being in a studio it was
a studio in Arizona that had an A B and
C room
and this was crazy in the a room
was
Swiss beats and Cassidy
it's like 2005. you're a kid
I'm 15. that's I'm a hustler
Cassidy in that money on top of the
world this was actually right after you
know what not I'm thinking this was
right after I think Cassidy was in a was
he in a car accident you know this after
he recovered from his car accident you
know what I'm saying
him Miss Swizz Beatz was in um Studio A
and bone was in Studio B
and mighty mot Thug five was in Studio C
the next hits of the world right there
yeah like
um honestly man
uh my uncle lay had the vision you know
what I'm saying but bone was working on
their album
and um Swizz Beatz was doing some work
on their album as well and like they
were supposed to be focused and my uncle
they really tried to
set something up for us to try to take
advantage of that didn't take away from
bone because they knew they had that
Studio C and um we blew it you know what
I'm saying they put an Xbox or some [__]
in the apartment we was in [__] wasn't
writing a verses and now don't get me
wrong
and they'll let you know if you ever
talk to them I always have my verses
ready I showed up I always knocked my
verses out easy like but you know it
took it took them a lot longer me and my
little brother
um
we was always smooth you know what I'm
saying but
you know the other three played the
video games and different things like
that and we played the video games too
it was all just kids but anyways
um
j-bone my cousin Jay Bone lazy bone son
took the BB gun and accidentally shot
the backboard out
of the basketball court y'all got a
basketball court outside just like that
[Music]
the BB gun and shot the damn backboard
out some kind of way shattered the [__]
bro we was on the next flight home the
next day the group was over [__] Mighty
both Thug five was finished [__]
started it was expensive BB gun video
games
you know and
I love you wish but wish was
like get these little [__] out
of here man they destructive you know
what I'm saying so Mighty Mo Thug five
never worked
um my uncle lay Vision never got to come
to life but
you know I was able to go off and and do
my own thing and um so was everybody
else
and he got to see it all turn into what
it is but like yeah I never told that
story uh that might people be like
sometimes like man you know they had
that have helped them a lot along the
way and things like that and you know
those stories you don't you can't kind
of like clear it all up right so you
just kind of let it be what it's gonna
be but like there was a time where my
uncle like did really try to make
something happen for us and we blew it
yeah I'm saying Mighty Mota 5 was over
the fact is and we blew it man did you
Swizz Beatz is probably my favorite
producer like did you see him in there
working in children I'll tell you
um I saw Swiss beats um
um we never got a chance to talk to him
or anything because he was in the vibe
but Cassidy did come in there and talk
with us and had a conversation with us
and talked to us about you know proper
preparation you know one of the greatest
writers of all time yeah like being
prepared being ready you know he he he
had music that he was sitting on and
like [__] that he was ready for just in
case it jumped off you know and um he
just came in and gave us a lot of games
so that was cool you know what I'm
saying but
it all it all ended so quick you know
what I'm saying yeah man like my mom was
done after that she was like ah yeah
[__] y'all went out there and blew it
done with this [__] I was like a 90s
movie
it really does do you have all these
songs from back when you were like eight
nine ten eleven years old yeah bro I got
a lot of them songs I'm dusk you got a
couple of them I got it yeah yeah cause
my mom had him in the vote so I got a
couple of them bro oh that was I don't
have something you know oh I got a home
video of me at my birthday I don't have
that imagine you have your thoughts oh
not yo your mom's thoughts damn it never
mind
at least you got your little you yeah
you must have you rapping wrapping your
ass off with little headphones bigger
than you that's some good [__] to have
though oh my God good documentary
starter that's the opening to your
documentary word
what a unique story
I love that damn I feel like I should oh
you're only smoking grapples huh
no problem
so we like to ask everybody in music if
we had to do like uh all-time poll on
your like Spotify of Life of who you've
listened to most lifetime where do you
think who do you think it would be right
now
yeah I don't really listen to Spotify I
mean Just Like Music you're music
listening like lifetime playlist you
know what artists you think would be at
the top that you've listened to and
inspired you the most
um
bone would be at the top
so yeah it's kind of hard to not when
you and you're seeing it and you're
seeing like oh they're successful and
they're one degree away I can be there
and then you start making music I could
see how that couldn't be your answer
yeah it kind of has to be yeah I guess
that's like
when you're growing up in it yeah and
plus growing up in it and you said
you're a youth reporter you're the
little boy asking people [__] you're
running award shows and stuff yeah how
was that what even we glided right over
that [__] yeah yeah I was on Nickelodeon
no what happened what happened
you know what's crazy is um I recently
talked to my mom about this because
there's like a little kid you know that
um be at the Raider games and he'd be um
interviewing the the Raider the players
that the Raider players right and he's
like a little dude and um and I see him
and uh
I had to see if he had a social media
you know and I just to see if his
parents was running his social media and
of course they are and I and I just
couldn't help but think like wow like I
couldn't imagine if my mom had a
platform to broadcast what she was able
to
do with us you know what I'm saying and
that's the big thing is like we did a
lot of that youth reporting [__] but
like after it was just right back to
the regular [__] you know what I'm
saying we never got nothing out of that
like there was like
we didn't get paid to show up in and be
youth reporters you know most of the
time my mom started talking about how we
have to stretch the money you know to
make this [__] happen you know what I'm
saying and we have a bunch of pictures
and with a bunch of different people you
know what I'm saying like I interviewed
Nate Dogg oh [__] you know and you I
interviewed a lot of different people
what'd you ask him
a question that's a great question
um I I truly don't remember but I tell
you this my mom had we had
this [__] was very structured you know
what I'm saying like my mom we went over
these questions and like
she made like these little books of
questions that we could ask and you know
this [__] was very
yeah she was super organized for sure
were you confident are you like nervous
like going up to this
adult first of all
years old yeah no I was I was confident
I think like yeah I was confident until
the rap [__] started like when I got on
stage that was different I realized like
all the eyes on me at once was a lot
different than
like me interviewing somebody and kind
of paying attention to somebody and the
eyes being on me but like having to
control the crowd that first time I was
like oh I don't know if I can do this
how old were you the first time uh
10 I think yeah I can barely get my kid
to like order something at a restaurant
waiter and [__] yeah I was 10. this is a
Magic Johnson event and out here in
California
you traveled for your fur oh that was so
much better yo you got a lot of
confidence inside as a kid I remember
the first time I did it was wrestling a
sport thing where you're you're the one
on the fan I was like
people are looking at me right and I was
I was nine like
guess I'll get it I'll do it right that
was scary but you on stage uh we just
did a TED talk first time I've ever been
on stage like that
I'm so glad I wasn't nine years old
because I would not have made it you
know what I'm saying like oh yeah I
couldn't even imagine a child with that
kind of pressure oh God hell no I wasn't
about I was feeling like a child okay I
guess yeah imagine being a kid like that
dude is there anything that you think
that to like is there anything that you
like say to yourself or do that it's got
a damn report or the valedictorian
speech they gotta do what did you go in
with that like I got this what what did
you say to yourself because I was like
myself you're a child like what did you
do to psych yourself out you're going on
stage and you're trying oh I was super
like I was in the mirror I was confident
yeah oh you're doing it yeah yeah I went
out there yeah I quit after that first
show though
but then you know my mom got on my
[__] head about quitting being a
quitter like she got on my top and like
she's like we don't quit you know what
I'm saying and like we just find
different ways to handle it and deal
with it you know what I'm saying on some
Joe Jackson [__] and like I [__] I
[__] it's like all right cool well
like now I know at least what to expect
but like I went up there and I I I froze
up a little bit like I think I started
to move a little bit like I remember
right before we went on stage my first
show I never forget this
um
they had a mic with a cord and then a
cordless mic
and the dude was like it was me and my
little brother
he was like all right which one of y'all
want the the cordless mic and my mom was
like give him the cordless mic to me I
was like he gonna be the one moving
around
I was like damn
my brother had the core Mike he was over
there rocking that [__] his little ass
he didn't give a [__] like he didn't
have a you weren't nervous at all my
little brother
shout out to my little brother he kept
that first show me I froze up like a
little like a little hoe
and I quit after that you know what I'm
saying and then you know my mom
talked to me and convinced me that like
you know that happens
and that you can bounce back
and I end up bouncing back and I don't
know
I just started to be more I just
realized that I had to be more confident
in myself for real wow I love this so
much this is the Epic the confidence you
juice a kid up with like that kind of
throw him in the deep end a little bit
by the way
of course
oh damn yeah yo where's this little mini
movie seriously that's all I'm seeing is
this little this little you and your
little brother I'm imagining everything
I could see your outfits right now
freezing up on stage
[Laughter]
dude wireless mic these kids are
different breed I couldn't get you
couldn't get a handful in all of America
to do what you just yeah you guys had
Tick Tock oh you definitely oh come on
yeah yeah if you had an outlet like you
said earlier anything because you know I
got I got pictures with everybody and
like you know and growing up I used to
just
it didn't really get us nowhere so those
pictures and [__] would irritate me
sometimes like I don't really like
talking about them or showing the homies
or none of that [__] but
now that I'm older and now that I see
how I see these kids and what they're
doing and how their parents are
utilizing these platforms to to create a
platform for their kids you know what
I'm saying to be able to do something
cool
and to be able to show the world to
inspire other kids that's the thing is
like what we were doing
we didn't have a way to show we didn't
have anything to show us that we were
inspiring other kids so we had a we had
a
um
we had a
uh like uh what do you call it
um article like called JFK just for kids
news you know what I'm saying that was
my mom's [__] like we're gonna call it
JFK just for kids you know the structure
in this for you guys yeah and what we're
gonna do is you're gonna go around and
you're gonna ask the the [__] that kids
want to know you know what I'm saying so
she came up with all these different
questions
but like we would go do it and we
wouldn't
we didn't have any way to know
if it was inspiring anybody like there
was nothing to put it on it was just
like going and collecting
information and [__] and no feedback no
feedback doing service and like my mom's
putting it together and trying to shop
it and she's getting feedback and all
this different [__] and telling us these
different things but you know we just at
the crib like okay
well let us know when it's not working
out
you know and then it would be another
event that's like
that didn't really lead to anywhere and
then another event that didn't really
lead to anywhere and you're like
constantly meeting famous people that
people would be like super excited about
but you're like
why do we keep going to hang around
these [__] that got it all
figured out again like oh man how does
it make sense yeah like
and it's just like it's gonna happen one
day and it's just like all right I
didn't know you grew up with one of
these kids yeah the kids you see like in
movies it sounds like a [__] movie
right
so then from like you said you're 15 you
kind of start break away from that doing
your own thing of music
yeah yeah so then how did we get to this
to you in the Gated Community just doing
your music well 15 to 22 right is you're
building up this family because base
essentially when I first saw you
I heard one of your songs about who is
this and then I followed you on
Instagram
I followed you and I commented and then
you commented back before DMs and then
you followed me I'm like this was cool
as hell I like this guy that I met you
at a Cannabis Cup that's all I remember
like yo this guy this music is sick you
know I followed that was it because you
know me with music I'm a [__] and I
you know if I hear it I'm like I like
this is my sh this is what I like so
that's that's how I found you from 15 to
22 you're building up after you're
taking off on your own and I've meet you
at 22 you already had a bro you're
already doing your thing so from 15 to
21 essentially what were you doing
you're doing your own thing you're doing
your shows doing High School [__] shaky
um it's true oh what story is coming out
right now it is tricky
um so I was actually living in
um I went from Vegas to Covington
Georgia
um family out there
um no I actually moved out there with a
friend
um my mom
uh my boy dujon I had started we had
started a group called The Future
um when I was in eighth grade and my boy
it was me my little brother and my boy
dujon who at the time he went by Young D
you know what I'm saying and uh he was
about to move to Covington Georgia
and I kind of didn't want the group to
break up and kind of jokingly I just was
like man I wish I could go out there
with y'all cause I'm
we stacked up in my apartment
and then he was like I asked my mom you
ask your mom
and then yeah long story short
I was I started uh ninth grade in
Covington Georgia
yeah 13 14 you left I was yeah 14 I was
in Covington Georgia with the honey and
I went out there to the country you know
I didn't know how country that was going
to be you know I went a world there's
weeds I'm assuming yeah so I went out
there and got a real like self
experience you know what I'm saying
um I went to Birmingham I
and yeah
some kind of way
you know my mom ended up moving the
family to Covington Georgia
so I have found a crib out there that
was like
extremely in the country fully furnished
you know and the same
vicinity is where my homeboy would stand
and like
it was big as hell and it was half the
price of what she was paying in Vegas
and yeah I convinced her to like you
found this place as like a fortune I
found this spot like
on my bike coming home from like playing
basketball at this random house that I
met at school and I heard full grown man
so were you looking for an apartment
like no I was just staying with the
homie like but I had just seen the crib
it had said for rent and I was just like
looking dawned on you I'm looking at the
crib and I'm like looking at the
bedrooms and I'm like I hit my mom like
how many bedrooms is it
what you paying
I'm like I'm looking at a house right
now that's like half that and it's big
as [__] it's in the country though
it's it's it's you can only go this way
and that way it's going one way this
country
um and yeah she ended up coming out
there didn't work out you know what I'm
saying like being in the country wasn't
for my mom's wasn't for the family at
all
so we ended up in California
and
I came to California and that's how I
ended up at Hollywood High
you know what I'm saying we we went
right to a hotel down the street from
Hollywood High and I was school yeah
I stay right around all these crazy
[__] I used to go up there and
see them the [__] dancing on
Hollywood Boulevard all this [__] at
like 15. like I was going to Hollywood
right there damn and you already
experienced all the [__] that these kids
are trying to get done I'm trying to be
a reporter but I already did that [__]
moved to the country and now I'm back in
this [__] yeah bro your Life's a move
yeah know about that yeah it was it was
too wild bro I came back and you know
coming back from the the country
um to come into California you know
um
it was just a whole nother world were
you excited for that like do you want
that
um
that I want to move from Covington yeah
yeah yeah
it was kind of like everybody was just
unhappy you know nothing was walking
distance were you still wanting to make
music like yeah I'm it's probably better
if I go out to California no no I'm not
when we start going to California I
wouldn't think about music no more like
that I was like man I just want to play
basketball gotcha so I went to Hollywood
High and I made the team I played on the
basketball team nice and I think I
finished my ninth grade year
at um Hollywood High
and um
from there I ended up in
Santa Clarita
that's where my mom got an apartment and
I ended up at a school called Golden
Valley Golden Valley that's one of
Merced too yeah same one I went to and
said so I went to Golden Valley out
there
and you know
that led to to my mom's losing that
apartment and wanting to go back to
Flint so I'm originally from Flint my
mom wanted to go back to Flint and
revamp restart you know what I'm saying
but I ain't want to go back to Flint you
know I wanted to stay in California you
know so
once again I moved in with a friend
she was a stud though she was the homie
but
I stayed with her and her brother and
her parents and they brought me in and
things like that and I was finishing
school out here because I didn't want to
switch schools I had already switched
school so many times
I'm like I ain't gonna pass no goddamn
grades like it was really to so I could
like finish school and [__] like that
and then just figure it out with my moms
when school was over
well um
well shout out to Chelsea that was her
name who brought me and her and her
family where they had an aunt that
worked in the country for six months and
out of the country for six months and
um
you know when she was out of the country
her sister who was Chelsea's mom would
just go check on the house and feed the
dog and different things like that but
she said you know I have been around for
a long time she said that I could just
crash at the crib while she was gone
and uh the whole house
whole house with a big ass wolf that I
had to feed
yo what movie script did you pull this
[__] from
I had to feed him
[Laughter]
yo this [__] was um
it was an experience Yeah man so now I'm
I'm yeah living in a in a [__] taking
care of this crib for um
Chelsea's Aunt while she's out of the
country and uh I'm going to school doing
my thing got a little girlfriend
everything everything was cool you're
going to school while staying on your
own in the house at 16. yeah very
disciplined just keep going yeah on me
the bus you know all I had to do was
walk to the bus stop yep and then you
know catch the bus back and walk back to
the crib so it was pretty set up and
Chelsea's mom helped me
help me with the groceries and make sure
I had the food for the dog and you know
her her whole Focus was just me
finishing school you know what I'm
saying and yeah I had my little
girlfriend so it was what it was like
but it was lonely kind of you know what
I mean like my my brothers everybody was
kind of scattered you know what I'm
saying
and in my mom's out of nowhere hit me
and was like I moved back to Vegas
I'm living on I'm back on Boulder
Highway
and I'm like oh
she's like all your brothers is here
your sister is here everybody oh Lord
everybody back in the crib
I'm like damn I'm over here living in
this [__] crib with this wolf
right now
out here in California and I got a
girlfriend
I'm like damn you know what I'm saying
uh but I like miss my family like miss
my brothers and [__] so you only had six
months right she was coming back
who my mom the lady that lived in the
house right oh yeah I only had six
months yep so I don't even think I was
there for the full six months
um
I think I was there uh
maybe three or four months that I was
there
um and then my mom hit me and said that
she was back in Vegas so I um
yeah I decided to go back to Vegas you
graduated and yeah stay with my mom
um
but then my mom's kicked me out
there over what
tripping with her [__]
because he was tripping with my little
brother
so it it was tricky I'm like
he tripping with him how you not how I'm
not gonna trip with him and my mom
tripped with me so yeah I ended up
having she gave me a crazy ultimatum and
I ended up having to leave
but at the time you know I had found
somebody that had a home studio
and you know growing up in the music
industry the way I grew up I had never
really seen like a home studio like that
it was always bigger Studios and
it always seemed like it had to be a
bigger situation so I kind of like
really didn't want no smoke with the rap
[__] because it always felt like
you had to try to put on a persona like
because my mom always wanted us to be
positive and do all this [__] it was
like you had to put on this
positive Persona and [__] like that so
you know I didn't really [__] with it
but I found this home studio and I'm
like
you know shout out to my boy uh r3d you
know what I'm saying because he was one
of the first people that I seen
recording himself
and uh
I could actually hear his vocals over
the beat and then I'm like oh that's
crazy
I'm like this crazy I'm like can I
can I get out
like can you record me because I got
like
some books of [__] [__] and I just and
he's like yeah you just we get the
instrumentals and like I'm like cool so
I started recording with him and then I
just started uploading it to Myspace
and like you know I was getting some
cool little feedback I'm like all right
this cool like you know but there was a
platform for me to upload the music
I had never had that before you know
what I'm saying so to be able to get
feedback it kind of like had my wheels
turned in a little bit you know what I'm
saying so but I have been in California
and I had picked up a lot of
game and a lot of knowledge and I have
been in the South and I had picked up a
lot of gaming a lot of knowledge and a
lot of games from Michigan the Midwest
and in Vegas and you know I'm like maybe
I could just
find a way to intertwine all this [__]
you know what I'm saying and yeah I just
started making the music and
yeah it just started
drawing from there out of Vegas yeah we
always known as the same name
nah so what was the first one it's the
first name you picked the first name was
Lil Ronnie little Ronnie little Ronnie
was the first name yeah
um
little Ronnie was my first name and then
um dizzy D flashy was my second name
and then are we going all the way back
yeah okay all the way back Lil Ronnie
was my name for the longest when you
were rapping as a kid yeah gotcha yeah
that was a little Ronnie and then
um I became a dizzy D flashy when I got
to high school
so
yeah in high school I was throwing
parties
and you know [__]
like when I was in California I had seen
like the jerk movement kind of like oh
damn making his waves you know what I'm
saying and I was like this is fire you
know what I'm saying and I got to Vegas
you know my mom's hit me out the blue
and was like she back in Vegas so I just
ended up in Vegas but I had been in Cali
for a little while you know what I'm
saying
and when I got to Vegas like you know
they wasn't on nothing like
they wouldn't hit the none of this [__]
like I'm like y'all ain't heard of YG
day of third oh you guys are out here in
the desert I'm like you know they
eventually got on it but when I first
got there
you know the style everything was was
very behind in high school you know I
don't know what the other [__] was
doing [__] Gotta understand that I was
in high school you know what I'm saying
um
because you know how grown [__] be
coming out and be like [__] we was on
that yeah he also 31 years old I'm
talking about the [__] young [__]
that was in high school
um
so anyways I came out there and I just
started throwing parties and I was kind
of playing that California music that I
had
got hit too when I was out there and it
made my parties a little different you
know what I'm saying I felt like it
wasn't just the music that was on the
radio you could come and hear some
different West Coast [__] and there were
some dances to it you know what I'm
saying and
the Cali [__] started coming to Vegas
and they started showing out you know
parties yeah because I had homies in
California that I was telling and they
would come out for your high school
parties how fat are these well see there
was a there was a teen club called Club
Frozen
and you know shout out to Sam he gave me
two weekends
out the month you know every other
weekend so I got to throw a little party
with a little
um
theme you know what I'm saying with a
different theme might be an all-white
party or whatever you know phone party
whatever right and um
yeah like
we could
we started to be able to have like
little performers come through so there
was some rappers and different people
who was doing their thing in the city or
whatever like and Cali and we would tell
them like come do your song
that [__] going up out there come
perform it in Vegas and they would come
out and they would do their thing in the
Vegas [__] would do their thing and
then it started to come where the Vegas
[__] would battle the Cali [__] and
it would just be you know just like a
dope ass time like you know competitive
everybody was trying to show off they
moves it was just like some young [__]
[__] man it was fun as hell and I was
throwing them thanks you know so what I
started doing was like making you know
some Jerk songs like and I just started
slipping the [__] into the
rotation I was just like hey man just
throw this in the rotation let's just
see what they do live and I seen that
you know people would just like [__]
with the music and I'm just like okay
all right
I could probably you know what I'm
saying I could probably do this like
they [__] with it and um yeah from
there I just got inspired like to just
you know like do this [__] but really it
was like you know YouTube and
um all that [__] was so new that I was
like all right well if I do a video I'm
just gonna do videos to my real [__]
and I just put like the jerk [__] out on
like Myspace and like keep that [__]
separate you know what I'm saying so I'm
I'm still in the club but I'm not
necessarily
um
trying to be that artist I'm carving out
a lane for me to be an actual hip-hop
artist right to be able to talk about
[__] because that was kind of always the
plan
so yeah and that's how all this [__]
really just a story though that's how
you're throwing your own parties
all right so this is a that that's your
water by the way this is a a movie also
you said you just want to play
basketball
so you're good at basketball
you would say you're good
um I got a little story for you that you
may remember you probably don't because
you do a lot of things
um this is confirmed and I have it on a
hard drive somewhere okay one time you
invited me to your show and there was a
Santa Cruz so me and Rosie go out to the
show shows dope uh
super sick show's over
you're about to go outside and you're
like yo I'm Gonna Change do my thing and
you come back in like all right cool and
there's
40 fools looking through that back
window of the Catalyst trying to look
back into the because you they know
you're still chilling right
Hugo is that a basketball hoop
and they wheeled out the basketball
I haven't been able to play oh and you
started drilling oh oh he's good do you
remember what happened after this or no
I don't all right oh here we go it's
like you weren't even there here we go
so we started playing basketball and
that's the day I realized like damn I'd
even bring my belt I'm holding my and
I'm
I love basketball so I'm like hell yeah
I'm a play you
me your drummer the live drummer the
dude with a big afro I don't know who he
was four other fools
DJ Hoppa
and I think that's it like seven people
we played a full full game to 21. ones
and from far you know hella far I might
count as two this man's good at
basketball right I found out he's very
good at basketball so we're playing
basketball we're going for a [__]
hour you're playing hard you're pouring
everyone's competitively pushing each
other down back and then shooting he's
shooting everybody's doing their thing
the fans are doing this with their
phones through the back we're playing
for a full hour this tour bus is right
outside so everything's outside it gets
better don't just wait everybody's going
to 21 and you say if you don't hit on 21
you go back to like yeah a 15 or 18 I'm
like oh God man that's demoralizing it's
horrible security guards are at the door
just kind of waiting because they have
to take you to the bus and everyone
nobody's left and they eventually open
the doors and all the fans are around
the middle of the Catalyst stage right
and they're all in this game I have been
on tape I will find it before this
episode comes out this dude hits the
final shot makes it everyone erupts like
we're in a stadium do you remember all
right here we go this bull jumps up into
these people they pick him up on the
shoulder start carrying him out and he's
doing this
and they carry him to the [__] bus
outside Benny Rodriguez
they pick him up everybody's like
look at this [__] guy they picked him
up and they were you had a like a little
like a shaved little you had like a flat
topper yeah that's when someone snatched
your head off your head and I had it on
tape and then you snatched it back while
you had the microphone in the show this
is the same show from a makeshift pickup
game well it was a full-on like damn I
haven't played in a minute I shot
someone else shot
let's do it let's go to five and then it
went on to you took your shirt off and
everyone's playing hard as hell
um I had to drive back to September said
but the fact that he turned around on
the sea of people
and look at all of us yeah you won for
it was the best [__] ever it was like a
movie it was like the end of Air Bud uh
Disney movie and I told that story on
the show before when we brought you up
one time season one but very small it
was amazing so yeah I know you're good
at basketball I was there
that's literally it that's all I wanted
to say I remember when they wrote that
out I do
good I'm glad it didn't happen so often
that you just end up in little games
that lead to them carrying you off
shot oh then you start dribbling and
then just uh Rosie sat there for an hour
and a half was watching us
so that's my story that's what I
remember from that day it was at the
cows in Santa Cruz I'll never forget
that that's awesome yeah so whenever you
do your movie you can end it with that
right that's a great Ender and then it
bleeds to Black it's like a Disney movie
all right my bad that was an amazing ass
story you just told you should you
should make a movie of your life and
that was that was just asking about
music you're a good Storyteller man very
good Storyteller what a story
I don't even know how long how long
we've been I have no idea
oh we've only been oh it's the weed yeah
I haven't been here that long all right
good I just wanted to make sure we're
good so yeah he's good Mario used to
play college basketball Marty's good at
basketball too I'm not
yeah we just we had Matt Barnes in here
and went over it our most embarrassing
moments on board and all that they do
all the smoke right here on this on this
set right here so Matt Barnes Steven
Jackson right here and they got Kevin
Garnett somewhere I don't know we're in
a oh it's Tyson we're in a room full of
uh athletes and I'm the only one that's
like
I could dribble right
um that's dope though yeah it's dope
it's dope do the uh
good story
all right now I know you mentioned when
you mess with the the gravel Leaf right
yeah so is that your like on your free
time is that the main way you [__] with
weed yeah it is what about like Edibles
dabs mushrooms [__] like that you
venture off that stuff no not right now
just flour really I'm just I have you
know I haven't done mushrooms yet
um you put mushrooms yet at all at all
yeah
um I plan to indulge though very fun for
you
um but
yeah
um I dabbed and not yeah I've done it
all Edibles everything but yeah right
now I'm just smoking the flour yeah and
that's like part of the whole process as
far as writing recording and maybe
that's you're listening too yeah oh I
didn't realize that it's his own line
with crown yeah criminal G right yeah
yeah oh no [__] I didn't realize that
yeah that little face that's yeah I
don't know if you still have the the
same logo actually the Hat yep and in
Vegas it's with redwood cultivation so I
have different flavors with them like we
have a flavor called heavy Jazz out
right now and
um smooth Funk is that inspired by the
album I'm assuming no actually it was
before the album so I guess yeah and
groovy OG so it's kind of like I was
already on on that wave yeah Rubio it's
like I manifested it you know then they
just came with the sound and we just
were able to make it work
so going back to that they come with
like a bunch of Beats or was it like
more collaborative yeah so
um Mike
um shout out to Mike because pretty much
the whole album
are Beats that were picked out the first
night
you know that I was just like
we were just listening to beats and I
just was like that one
that one that one it just gave them all
to me and the ideas got put down and
then we got together and then you know
it really all got curated do you like to
be like isolated like I'm gonna take
these beats and you'll see me in a
couple days and I'm gonna go come back
with these songs written
doesn't matter to me like you know I
could do it that way or like we could
get it in in a moment like we could do
it right now
don't bother me none I'm like you know
the music really just takes over for me
when it's time to create are you always
floating around with like Concepts and
bars and loose thoughts and stuff
written down where you can like pull
from
do I constantly do it throughout the day
yeah like do you have a notepad that's
always just full of thoughts that you
can pull from no or you just
everything's fresh yeah it's it's mostly
fresh now that's cool
like you know I'll
um
you know I go off of whatever is
processing you know so I go and I do
like my research and I like just live
life and listen to different podcasts
and different things like that and
whatever process that like sticks out or
gives me a feeling it's like that's the
energy I like go with all organic
basically yeah yeah
um before before I forget
do you remember the the crown OG dizzy
how that goes do you remember that the
conversation I remember do you remember
uh
from the picture how that happened you
remember or no uh-uh
no what you talking about the crown OG
how you guys met up or no
no what do you remember
I remember that my homie made a picture
of you out of wax using Crown oh Gog oh
yeah yeah and then the owner's like hey
I know you uh
you you've hung out with a guy before
I'm like yeah and then remember we
Linked In the text message
and then you guys went to you're like
yeah we should do some work together is
that that's exactly it was at the push
tree's house I was in front of the Apple
chandelier I have a great memory I was
like
yeah cause you made that picture of you
smiling out of wax remember he made it
dripped it and cut it I do remember that
yeah that's crazy like yeah I can piece
that together I only remember like where
I remember the start of
uh it's like the conversation that I
feel like I had after I was so stoned
when we were like initially meeting
right like I remember the conversation
when it was like oh so we feel like we
grow the best weed in the world and
nobody knows about it you know and I
remember and that's where I normally
started from but I I know prior to that
we all had to link right like yeah it's
crazy hearing that like that's crazy
yeah
remember I remember I told you a couple
years ago like
the Disney OG I was like yeah because
they were like they made a picture like
can you link us I'm like yeah and I just
sent you the picture like who made this
I remember that yeah it's a trip off
that is a trip years later dude and then
okay so speaking of filling in the blank
so you stopped before you got to dizzy
right so how did we get to that name
oh [__] we did
yeah so
um just realizing so as uh dizzy D
flashy I um
you know I had did a bunch of stuff like
I had performed on 106 in park and did
some different competitions
in high school
um oh [__] hold on what was who is the
host
uh Terrence and uh
Terence and uh
a proxy yeah yeah Terence Iraq they were
high school 106 in part yeah they're
going to your parties bro what happened
to your party you're gonna play
[__] parties but like listening ones
this is we're thinking about like some
my partner
no no girls are here
in a garage full of dudes
that's not what he's talking about
uh no it was um it was it was lots of
girls lots of fun lots of dancing
um and at this time you know like I mean
you know
Pretty Ricky was in and like
you know Chris Brown you know record was
clean you know it's like it was a
different time you know what I'm saying
um but we had a lot of fun back then so
or the Dizzy D flashy to me had got
really associated with the jerk movement
and the jerk movement had took a
mainstream turn and I didn't have
nothing to do with that mainstream turn
but I didn't like being like associated
with it more than the the actual music
that I was working on as projects so I
was doing mixtapes and my mixtapes
didn't represent I didn't put any Jerk
songs on
any mixtape ever you know what I mean
like
that was just stuff that I had on
YouTube and the DJs had you were doing
like an alias for the radio basically
yeah it was just like some [__] for the
DJs and for YouTube and like
there was like a little I would say kind
of like
viral moment that I had of a like dance
that somebody created it's like a tick
tock Dance Before Tick Tock that some
kid did when he
you know did some little dancing jumped
up in the air and clapped his hands and
then everybody started doing that and it
became like a little
thing you know what I'm saying so a lot
of people
knew me for that you know what I mean so
um I wanted to
separate myself from that so I decided
to just cut the the D flashy and
um just start using my regular last name
hmm
it's crazy because back in that time it
just felt like it was a huge decision
yeah I'm like this feels like a huge
difference giving up all the momentum
you have built up yeah because and uh
and uh everything was dizzy D flashy
through my YouTube so it was really just
going through my YouTube and changing
everything from D flashy to right
um
uh but it felt like such a big thing to
do you know at that time and like
um that was kind of the the shift
into
um
who I am today really
the juice like the things kind of start
and like taking off at that point
um
now I just got hungry like you know this
live at daddy Max time you know I'm
saying where like there was little shows
and things like that that were I was I
had dead
um
I performed at daddy Max's digid flashy
a few times you know so I was hungry to
get back out there as dizzy right you
know and
like revamp you know what I'm saying and
like
separate myself from The Jerk [__] and
the party [__] and you know get more on
the hip-hop [__] and the poetic [__] and
um
yeah that was kind of the the shifting
moment I just got really hungry after
that I started doing all the
competitions
everything and that's how I ended up
getting in front of the volume
and then from there yeah
that's where everything just took off
yeah the rest is history what's it like
you drop an album then you gotta kick
back and now all the comments all the
reviews come in I'm thinking about that
moment tonight whenever it drops yeah
like all your fans are so excited for it
then they get to appreciate it and it's
kicked back and your show tonight yeah
it's kicking off and so today's a great
day today's gonna be sick I'm glad you
I'm glad you're here on the day that
something so important yeah thank you
for that I'm glad I get to come and um
share these stories with y'all today
that's awesome
um it feels it feels good man honestly
it's like
it's like all right it's not it's not
just you and the homies
you know little
thing anymore you know like
now it's gonna belong to the world you
know what I'm saying and I think that
there's some beauty in that like
you know somebody's gonna feel good
somebody's gonna be inspired somebody's
gonna
it's gonna shift somebody's energy you
know what I'm saying and you know
I think that's that's awesome
yeah of course it's a great message to
put out there yeah that's what we at the
end of the episode I hope this helps
somebody
I hope somebody out there is thinking
different that's the whole tone of his
music too like exactly the message you
put out I'm sure when you meet fans in
person they tell you their life story
and the exact moment they heard
something goes that's when I started
thinking like this I'm sure you get it
all the time because you're a positive
person like that like you get
reciprocated the same thing right and we
put it out like we were talking about it
yesterday there's always a line I'm sure
you have it there's a line of an artist
that said something go I'll be connected
forever because of that just because you
can find relatability and like you say I
used to drop my name I remember I used
to drop my age so you could see where
I'm at my growing process yeah that also
is like yo I'm 29 yeah this Fool's going
through the same thing and I listened to
him right and then like oh you're more
you're not just an artist you're a human
being after that point and I feel like
uh people lose that a little bit when
it's about the like we said you didn't
get a bunch of Percocets and gun verses
and I think when that starts to happen
if that's who you are that's you know
you know that's what you know you're
going to be like it's not about his
images I like that kind of music too
yeah well that's not who I am that's all
yeah yeah your mom must be so happy
about how it turned out yeah I would I
mean you would have to you would have to
uh
ask her you know I'm saying
um but she's definitely proud of like
you know the type of artist that I
became you know what I'm saying it's um
yeah it's interesting man just like
it's interesting you know I know she
would like to be more a part of the
music industry and have more of a place
in the music industry you know but the
times are a lot different you know yeah
of course but now absolutely so where
can everybody find your album at you can
find it everywhere it's going to be on
all platforms every platform and you're
dropping them some of your music videos
on Dizzy Wright YouTube yeah so I'm
dropping
um my first music video
um for the album tomorrow at 10 am
and um it's called you get what you see
um the song's not out yet you'll hear it
in a couple hours on the album
and
yeah this this album is is different you
know
we're gonna get out here and we're gonna
pretty much
when when they listen to it it's gonna
be a live version of it you know they'll
be able to come out and see a live
version of it and we'll help it grow on
them before before it has to grow on
them and they'll be able to go back and
you know enjoy it sit with it and I
think it's going to be refreshing you
know what I'm saying so
yeah I'm excited whenever someone's
excited about their own [__]
that's that's a good good sign man I'm
excited and this is your first step you
say not it's not just with your homies
anymore it's
this is sick I'm excited man it's still
my homies it's not just but it's with my
it's with the creative minds if you
listen to nipsey's catalog when you get
to that uh Victory lap you can hear the
difference in the sound unquestionably
like absolutely oh damn somebody came in
here and like really put professional
polish on this
so I'm looking forward to hearing that
for sure yeah that's absolutely what
happened to me you know what I'm saying
this is definitely my most quality album
and I think it would be recognizable
right away
um
damn so what exact time's the trial
today
9 p.m oh tonight oh we got some time all
right and then what cities are coming up
we have uh LA tonight we have Phoenix
um tomorrow
and then I believe
um Flagstaff okay Flagstaff at Arizona
um I know we're going are we going to
Albuquerque
yeah yeah dizzy dizzywright.com
to check out the dates it's um mostly
the West Coast but we have more dates
that are coming out you know we gonna go
to the South to the east uh we also
going to Canada nice Australia and
Europe you know so we have a lot of
different dates that are coming out but
we starting with the West Coast we're
gonna go out there and uh celebrate this
new music with the West Coast first
you know because we know the west coast
is going to be able to appreciate this
right off the bat and
um we're gonna grow from here you know
yeah congratulations man thank you
brother it's a big day it's a big day
I'm excited like I said thank you for
coming here thank you for chilling
sharing the stories today was dope I
appreciate you a lot of time an
important day so thank you dude and when
you're in L.A come [__] chill I will
man and it's not even gonna say come to
my house man easy God I gotta come see
the crib come smoke and chill there's a
dab room and [__] yeah I love it I don't
have kids so I just made like uh that's
the dab station yeah in this room I have
a toy room bro all right
it's true that shit's sick though I like
that I'm gonna definitely slide that
yeah but no I appreciate you being here
guys uh anything else morning thank you
this was legendary I know how important
this was for the fans so you know we
love being in the place where people can
come on and like talk like this tell
their stories stuff we didn't know yeah
just really should make everything make
sense so thank you hell yeah well I'm I
hope it was insightful and I'm glad I
was here and uh anytime y'all need me
man just holla at me I'm always
appreciated Blown Away thank you man
thank you for being here guys uh thank
you so much for being here this has been
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast from Marty from Disney right and
I have a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie